the Falcon the Winter Soldier the vision
Peggy Carter and more here at d23 expo
hello Marta lights I'm Ryan aka agent M
here at d23 Expo 2019 now the Disney
Plus panel just ruled it was awesome and
Marvel Studios had so much cool stuff we
were very fortunate because we got to
talk to some of the creative minds and
the stars from their shows when in the
towards the end of the Infinity Saga did
you learn that this project was coming
there was on the horizon it was much
later for me
we have wrapped and it was probably
about 2 months a few months before the
movie yeah it was after infinity war but
before endgame
what were the reactions like for you
guys I remember as soon as we heard we
called each other I was like uh because
at first none of us like they at least
they told me they were like don't tell
Anthony right yeah work we want work you
know we're gonna talk to him so I didn't
and then we saw each other and I
remember going like so in that
discussion have you guys talked about
the title because it's the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier the Falcon is the Top
Billing on this how does that feel for
you and for you
like there's Starsky and Hutch I'm
pretty sure hutch ain't mad as Starsky
because what you gonna call it fell win
cun juror and on that note thank you
guys it was a blast I think one thing
that turned out to be great was watching
how Anthony and Sebastian are off-screen
and you see how natural they are so we
were able to pull a bunch of that stuff
and a bunch of those interactions as
well as the stuff to see it on screen we
they showed us outtakes that other
people haven't seen
and by the time we actually started
creating the project we really had a
sense of who they were well I think you
can look forward to a lot of action a
lot of comedy because we get to be
living with our characters for more than
the two-hour window that is typical of a
movie so we get to know and like them
and go on their journey and a lot of
emotion because at the same time as we
have a lot of comedy and and sort of a
you know Falcon in Winter Soldier and
how they are buddies together or not if
the case may be we also have some very
heartfelt moments Sharon Carter John
Walker love these characters in the
comics john is a bananas character and
of course I know them okay so I was
gonna ask I mean of course you've been
part of the MCU for so long but now
joining the MCU how much background work
you look into for the comics and for
these characters they gave me a Bible
about fistic of all the different comics
that Sharon Carter was in and it's crazy
because there's so many different
versions of these characters and so many
different you know ways to approach them
so it was really just like trying to
combine all the elements of her that I
liked in all the different ones and it's
fun they really let you kind of run with
the character and sort of take what you
want from all the different comments
which was a really fun process for me
and I get to do more of it did you get a
binder I've not gotten a binder yet okay
I will ask for a binder because that we
can do very I'm very helpful yeah and
what's it like joining the MCU now it's
great if you're lucky feel excited you
know it's fun to jump into something
that hasn't been seen I guess it's a
good time for the Carters to we got some
real fun stuff with Peggy and Sharon
it's it's real fun times yeah
it's gonna be cool I think we're gonna
see probably a different side of sheriff
Loomis
with it I mean I'm assuming so you guys
sitting in the crowd with all the fans
during the presentation and watching the
the teaser sizzle tone video and just
hearing them go what was it like for you
guys when you started to hear what this
show was gonna be it was when Kevin
started pitching it to us we were in set
we were we were pitched separately
though waiting I don't remember who was
pitch first but that doesn't matter but
no but I mean like I don't remember who
was physically in LA first to hear the
pitch but we couldn't wait for the other
person to like we're also hearing Ike
you know I think you did too I can't
remember honestly and it was like wait
did you hear
did you hear let's talk about it this is
so amazing and nuts and cool like like
we couldn't be I mean no one's saying
you have to do this
someone's saying this is an idea if you
guys want to be game and we were like
jumping on that ship real fast yeah it's
because it's really avant-garde and
weird and out where and that's how it
starts and then it just spirals into
this out-of-control messed up stuff that
then becomes this epic you know Marvel
finale and widget you I would never
thought in a million years that that was
the way it was going to go and we're so
excited that it is I yes I I was also
like whoa
you know I know just a little bit I
think we all know a little bit but not
very much what I've heard I am as a fan
I'm really excited really excited sure
yeah same exact reaction when they were
telling me what I do know now it was
like really that's amazing so yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be really really
different but also very marble and
that's gonna be good I am so thrilled
about what it's very exciting and so I
think seeing the teaser today of course
just opens more questions which is
exactly like what it should and it could
be that it could be something else it
could be whatever like it just is more
Pandora's box see stuff which is really
exciting
open it up thank you guys we can't say
too much obviously but we wanted to show
something that captured a little bit of
the tone in the spirit of it and we'll
let you draw your own conclusions from
the footage but it is a blend of classic
sitcom and big Marvel action that's
about all we can say today it's a Marvel
story so it can't always be puppies of
rainbows all the time so yeah we have
this accompany since it comes by their
nature are essentially conflict-free but
can't be like that man see you so what
if the premise is of the show is an
animation and it's the idea of ever tiny
but crucial point or detail of the story
changed what the consequences would be
so from my episode it's if Peggy Carter
had taken the serum herself and Steve
Rogers remained Steve Rogers early
skinny Steve and she had actually become
captain Carter and then she picks up the
shield and kind of goes on an adventure
so it's been great being here today and
seeing some fans dressed cos preparing
as as Captain Carter and seeing these
you know the side area of this of Peggy
taking out the shield herself is really
exciting the best thing about it is I
don't have to spend any time in her
makeup because it's just animation so I
could be in my pajamas if I want to
drinking cup of tea and that's very very
civilized and very nice to do but it's
what's great fun is to see they matched
a lot of the animation to the my
performance
with my vocal performance so the
animation does it feels that there's a
lot of detail done and focused on with
the expression which I love and they've
done it such a beautiful job of creating
this very visually pleasing world and I
think she looks amazing she looks
entirely capable of the the action that
she's required to do in it when we first
started talking about the shows and
stories who can tell one of the things
we came to pretty quickly is what did
the Peggy Carter became the first
Avenger
what has she got to throw the shield in
commandos because I think we all know
Steve Rogers super serum soldier or not
he's our first champion he would be
there leaving her supporting her tell
that story tell their romance from
another angle yes so exciting it also
Howard would have to be her BFF because
Howard's hilarious is Larry's crazy
animation you're allowed to do things
that you couldn't do in live-action or
if you did it would be a hundred million
dollars so you know what we're going to
a castle in World War two Germany you're
gonna show the battlefield Britain
unlike as much fun as humanly possible
it was crazy I mean we've got this
massive sandbox plan it's unlike just
you let the mines go and the only caveat
wasn't we're just we're ripping off the
cinematic universe specifically and so
and we've all seen the movies we've all
loved the movies and so it's just like
okay awesome what is something that
could be slightly different but insanely
entertaining in a new way and not what
you not what the majority people might
think when they first think what if blah
I think you know Loki's a character who
really changes scene to see moment to
moment and so as a writer that's such a
gift you can change direction a million
times and and so for us it just means
everything's on the table and then
because it's TV and we have more hours
we can just go to sometimes even more
comedic places and also sometimes even
more dramatic places and that's really
fun yeah so we're gonna take him on a
really exciting new journey and we're
gonna show a new part the MCU and yeah
we're six hours like we're just so
excited because you can really spend
time and like dig into this character
yeah just to echo Kate it's gonna be
really cool it's good you know we know
how much the fans love this character
that's something the creative team
talked about all the way through we
really take that seriously
we understand concerns we understand
what they're excited about and so we
want to give them what they want
sometimes but also really try and
surprise people so it's it's gonna be
really fun what a day Disney Plus coming
November 12th and there's so much cool
Marvel content on there you guys it's
incredible yeah I'm Ryan and this is
Marvel your universe